Napoleon was a lot of things, but modest wasn’t
one of them.
This is something no better proved than that
time he responded to being declared Emperor
of the French by planning an elaborate ceremony
that would see him stroll around wearing an
80 pound (37 kg) cape…
No, that isn’t a typo.
Although Napoleon was formally declared Emperor
of the French by the Senate on May 18, 1804,
his coronation wouldn’t actually take place
until December of that year, which is kind
of understandable when you realise just how
impossibly opulent the event itself was.
Planned months in advance and set to take
place in the famed Notre Dame cathedral under
the watchful eye of none other than the pope
himself (after a lot of negotiation), Napoleon
saw to it that the very streets themselves
were scrubbed clean, lest he be offended by
the sight of a speck of dirt or… other matter…
on his trip through central Paris.
(See: Did People Really Used to Throw Fecal
Matter Out Their Windows?)
So hotly anticipated was the event that many
people turned up to the cathedral the day
before, dutifully waiting outside for a chance
to watch the procession.
Despite the fact that Napoleon himself wouldn’t
arrive until around noon, the doors to the
cathedral itself ultimately opened at 6AM
the next morning, around which point the air
of Paris was filled with the sound of thundering
cannon fire.
The purpose of the cannon fire, beyond no
doubt terrifying local birds, was to wake
Napoleon who was asleep in a giant, opulent
bed.
He soon adorned himself in white satin underwear
covered in gold embroidery, silk stockings,
dressing gown, tunic, cape and sword.
As for the latter, he had the weapon accessorised
with a giant diamond attached to its pommel.
Before leaving, the Emperor stood dressed
in his finery and reportedly barked an order
for his wife’s lawyer, Raguineau, to be
brought before him.
The new emperor then sarcastically asked Raguineau
“Well now, Monsieur, do I have nothing but
a cape and a sword?”
Why the jab?
Well apparently Raguineau had once advised
Napoleon’s wife, Joséphine, not to marry
Napoleon as he was a man “who has nothing
but a cape and a sword”- a statement Napoleon
had evidently taken great offence to and wanted
to take the chance to bring up one last time
before being crowned the most powerful man
in all of France and, indeed, one of the most
powerful men in the world.
Napoleon and his entourage, which included
Pope Pius VII, then left for Notre Dame cathedral
led by a donkey ridden by the Pope’s crozier-bearer.
According to papal tradition, the crozier-bearer
was supposed to ride a mule, but owing to
trouble finding a mule, a donkey was deemed
suitable.
(See: What’s the Difference Between a Donkey
and a Mule?)
Upon arriving in the cathedral to thundering
applause, the sound of a several hundred person
choir, and yet more cannon fire, Napoleon
and Joséphine then donned giant, impossibly
fuzzy ermine-lined pimp capes weighing some
80 pounds each.
At this point walking around required the
help of four people for the soon to be emperor,
with these individuals trailing Napoleon lest
he have to comically lean forward and struggle
for every step.
As for his wife, Joséphine’s helpers were
none other than Napoleon’s sisters, Elisa,
Pauline and Caroline- a task they loathed
given their dislike of Joséphine, rumored
to be because of resenting her grace and sophistication.
At one point they reportedly flat out refused
to be the empresses’ entourage, but when
Napoleon made threats against them if they
didn’t, they acquiesced.
That said, it is noted that after being crowned,
Joséphine attempted to ascend to her throne
only to almost fall over backwards when her
helpers forwent their duty and remained at
the bottom of the steps.
It is generally stated that this was an intentional
jab at the woman.
However, that same thing happened to Napoleon
himself when his helpers likewise let him
ascend on his own, resulting in him initially
miscalculating the effort needed to drag the
cape up the steps and almost falling over.
So the common rumor that this was an intentional
slight at Joséphine is probably incorrect,
even if Napoleon’s sisters perhaps enjoyed
it either way.
Going back to the grand entrance- Napoleon’s
walk through the cathedral was accompanied
via a carefully orchestrated series of movements
from his entourage, all of which was planned
out in excruciating detail before hand with
dolls and a to-scale drawing of the cathedral.
Throughout the coronation, Napoleon stood
in his giant cape visibly bored, stifling
several yawns and by accounts spending much
of his time observing his wife in her diamond
encrusted dress instead of the proceedings.
Napoleon then shocked the crowd further by
snatching the crown before the Pope could
put it on his head and instead did it himself.
While this is often stated to have also shocked
and offended the pope himself, the truth is
that every tiny detail of the ceremony had
been painstakingly negotiated and planned
out, including Napoleon making sure he’d
get to crown himself.
Thus, the pope was well aware Napoleon was
going to do this, contrary to what is often
reported.
As to why Napoleon wanted this, he thought
it important to indicate that he was being
crowned Emperor not by the will of the Church,
but by his own merits and the will of the
French people.
Napoleon then crowned his wife empress, adorning
her with a crown it should be noted he specifically
asked her to continue wearing right up until
they went to bed that night…
The last thing he was heard saying to the
new empress before they left for their bed
chambers was “To whom will I leave all this?”
Unfortunately for Joséphine, she was unable
to get pregnant, which was a big problem for
Napoleon who, as he so aptly put, needed an
heir.
Her inability to provide an heir was somewhat
surprising given she’d already given birth
to two kids by her previous husband, General
Alexandre de Beauharnais, who had been guillotined
during the Reign of Terror.
Nevertheless, whether because of some complication
from her last pregnancy, Napoleon’s Le Petit
Caporel not firing enough rounds, or perhaps
her age (she was 41 at the time, 6 years Napoleon’s
senior) or a combination of all of these,
she remained barren as the Gobi.
This all resulted in Napoleon having the marriage
dissolved about five years later, marrying
the sprightly young 18 year old Duchess of
Parma, Marie Louise, with the hope that he’d
have better luck impregnating her.
However, despite while married he and Joséphine
having had affairs (including some in which
he sired offspring) and him casting her aside,
he apparently never lost his affection for
his first wife, nor she for him.
The former couple frequently wrote one another
remarkably intimate letters, with Napoleon
still often addressing her as “my love”,
writing about everything from day to day matters
to seeking council about matters of state.
They even visited each other on occasion.
As you might imagine, this was much to the
chagrin of his very jealous second wife, Marie
Louise, who no doubt was well aware that she
was only around instead of Joséphine because
of her baby making abilities.
And baby making she did do, rather quickly,
providing the heir Napoleon sought.
When Joséphine found out (after having been
sent away for political reasons during the
birth and announcement), she wrote Napoleon
this amazingly touching letter:
Amid the numerous felicitations you receive
from every corner of Europe…can the feeble
voice of a woman reach your ear, and will
you deign to listen to her who so often consoled
your sorrows and sweetened your pains, now
that she speaks to you only of that happiness
in which all your wishes are fulfilled!
… I can conceive every emotion you must
experience, as you divine all that I feel
at this moment; and though separated, we are
united by that sympathy which survives all
events.
I should have desired to learn of the birth
of the King of Rome from yourself, and not
from the sound of the cannon of Evreux, or
the courier of the prefect.
I know, however, that in preference to all,
your first attentions are due to the public
authorities of the State, to the foreign ministers,
to your family, and especially to the fortunate
Princess who has realized your dearest hopes.
She cannot be more tenderly devoted to you
than I; but she has been enabled to contribute
more toward your happiness by securing that
of France.
She has then a right to your first feelings,
to all your cares; and I, who was but your
companion in times of difficulty – I cannot
ask more than a place in your affection far
removed from that occupied by the Empress
Maria Louisa.
Not till you shall have ceased to watch by
her bed, not till you are weary of embracing
your son, will you take the pen to converse
with your best friend – I will wait…
Meanwhile, it is not possible for me to delay
telling you, that more than any one in the
world do I rejoice in your joy…
I do not suffer, while you are happy; and
have but one regret, in not having yet done
enough to prove to you how dear you were to
me….
She likewise wrote a letter to Marie Louise
in an attempt to bury the hatchet, as it were:
While you were only the second spouse of the
Emperor, I deemed it becoming to maintain
silence toward your Majesty.
That reserve, I think, may be laid aside,
now that you are become the mother of an heir
to the Empire.
You might have had some difficulty in crediting
the sincerity of her whom perhaps you regarded
as a rival; you will give faith to the felicitations
of a Frenchwoman, for you have bestowed a
son upon France.
Your amiableness and sweetness of disposition
have gained you the heart of the Emperor – your
benevolence merits the blessings of the unfortunate
– the birth of a son claims the benedictions
of all France.
How amiable a people, how feeling, how deserving
of admiration, are the French!
To use an expression which paints them exactly,
“They love to love.”
Oh, how delightful, then to be loved by them!
It is upon this facility, and at the same
time steadiness of affection, that the partisans
of their ancient kings have so long rested
their expectations; and here their trust is
not without reason…
It must be confessed, however, that the Revolution,
without corrupting the heart, has greatly
extended the intelligence, and rendered the
spirits of men more exacting.
Under our kings, they were satisfied with
repose, now they demand glory.
These, Madame, are the two blessings, the
foretaste of which you have been called to
give to France.
She will enjoy them to perfection under your
son, if, to the manly virtues of his sire,
he join those of his august mother, by which
they may be tempered.
At one point, Napoleon even brazenly tried
to get the two women together, hoping they’d
become bosom buddies, presumably allowing
him to have Joséphine around on occasion.
For Joséphine’s part, she was very keen
on the idea.
However, Napoleon would write of the disastrous
attempt,
I wished one day to take [Marie Louise] to
Malmaison, but she burst into tears when I
made the proposal.
She said she did not object to my visiting
Joséphine, only she did not wish to know
it.
But whenever she suspected my intention of
going to Malmaison, there was no stratagem
which she did not employ for the sake of annoying
me.
She never left me…
Still, however, when I did happen to go, I
was sure to encounter a flood of tears and
a multitude of contrivances of every kind.
Joséphine, as always, was accommodating,
writing, “But [Marie] rejected this proposal
with such manifest dissatisfaction, that it
was not renewed.
I am sorry for it; her presence would have
given me no uneasiness, and I might have bestowed
good counsel as to the best means of pleasing
the Emperor…”
Of course, as noted, this didn’t stop Napoleon
and Joséphine from incessantly writing to
one another.
In fact, reportedly unlike many other correspondence,
Napoleon nearly always immediately stopped
whatever he was doing to tear open any letter
from Joséphine immediately upon receiving
it, even occasionally interrupting meetings
while campaigning to do so.
When his son was around two, he also began
secretly allowing Joséphine to see the boy
so she could get to know him.
This, however, didn’t last owing to the
risk that the growing boy would accidentally
reveal this fact to his mother.
As Joséphine wrote to Napoleon,
Assuredly, Sire, it was note mere curiosity
which led me to desire to meet the King of
Rome: I wished to examine his countenance-
to hear the sound of his voice, so like your
own- to behold you caress a son on whom centre
so many hopes,- and to repay him the tenderness
which you lavished on my own Eugene.
When you recall how dearly you loved mine,
you will not be surprised at my affection
for the son of another, since he is yours
likewise, nor deem either false or exaggerated
sentiments which you have so fully experienced
in your own heart.
The moment I saw you enter, leading the young
Napoleon in your hand, was unquestionably,
one of the happiest of my life….
Still I am perfectly sensible, Sire, that
those meetings which afford me so much pleasure,
cannot be frequently renewed, and I must not
so far intrude on your compliance as put it
often under contribution.
Let this sacrifice to your domestic tranquillity
be one proof more of my desire to see you
happy.
Later when Napoleon was banished to Elba,
this put Joséphine in a somewhat precarious
political position of still being an unapologetic
Napoleon supporter and former wife of the
emperor.
In fact, she even technically still held the
title of empress, as Napoleon himself had
decreed, “It is my will that she retain
the rank and title of empress, and especially
that she never doubt my sentiments, and that
she ever hold me as her best and dearest friend.”
She needn’t have worried as her reputation
preceded her, with Tsar Alexander I writing
to her of her status, “I have never heard
your name pronounced but with benedictions.
In the cottage, and in the palace, I have
collected accounts of your angelic goodness…”
As for Napoleon, his wife and son did not
join him on Elba, resulting in Joséphine
offering to do so,
…Ah!
Sire, why cannot I fly to you!
Why cannot I give you the assurance that exile
has no terrors save for vulgar minds, and
that, far from diminishing a sincere attachment,
misfortune imparts to it new force!
I have been on the point of quitting France
to follow your footsteps, and to consecrate
to you the remainder of an existence which
you so long embellished.
A single motive restrained me, and that you
may divine.
If I learn that, contrary to all appearance,
I am the only one who will fulfill her duty,
nothing shall detain me, and I will go to
the only place where henceforth there can
be happiness for me, since I shall be able
to console you when you are there isolated
and unfortunate!
Say but the word, and I depart.
Adieu, Sire; whatever I would add would still
be too little; it is no longer by words that
my sentiments for you are to be proved, and
for actions your consent is necessary…
Of course, being still married, Napoleon seemingly
could not give that consent.
And, unfortunately for both of them, Joséphine
died suddenly not long after.
Her last recorded words, reportedly spoken
in front of Tsar Alexander I, who was visiting
at the time, and her son Eugene and daughter
Hortense, were:
At least I shall die regretted; I have always
desired the happiness of France; I did all
in my power to contribute to it; and I can
say with truth to all of you now present at
my last moments, that the first wife of Napoleon
never caused a single tear to flow.
As for Napoleon, when he received the news
that Joséphine had died, he locked himself
away for two days.
About seven years later, when lying on his
own deathbed, his last recorded words were:
“France, the Army, the Head of the Army,
Joséphine.”
“Joséphine” wasn’t actually named that.
Her real name was Marie-Josèphe-Rose Tascher
de la Pagerie.
Before Napoleon, she always went by Rose,
but he disliked that name and began calling
her Joséphine, a slight variant of “Josèphe”.
He was the first to call her that, but as
he liked it, for the rest of her life she
went
by
that name.